vous savez qu'une organisation secrète
connue sous le nom des illuminati nous
manipule dans l'ombre pour établir un
nouvel ordre mondial complot
[Musique]
selon une célèbre théorie du complot les
illuminati sont une société secrète qui
tirait les ficelles du pouvoir aux
coulisses pour dominer le monde mais
d'où ça vient cette théorie déjà fun
fact à l'origine les illuminati ont
réellement existé on les appelait aussi
les illuminés de bavière cette histoire
nous amène la nuit du 1er mai 1776 au
coeur d'une forêt bavaroise près
d'ingoldstadt en allemagne notre
personnage principal s'appelle adam
weishaupt il est prof de droit canonique
alors c'est pas ce qu étudier les cas
non c'est plutôt ceux qui étudient les
lois régissant l'église catholique du
genre le pain sur la table c'est à
l'endroit et à l'envers le vendredi
c'est le jour du poisson et le dimanche
suit des patates au beurre et donc c'est
dans cette forêt que ce bond à dents et
ses quatre poteaux se sont dit comme ça
au débotté et si on se faisait une bonne
petite omelette aux girolles en rentrant
est aussi venez au fond d'une société
secrète pour s'affranchir de l'influencé
de la religion sur le gouvernement ait
apporté au peuple une nouvelle forme
d'illumination ce qui se rapproche un
peu des idéaux des philosophes des
lumières dont va être apte à lui tous
les bouquins quand il était petit et oui
c'était avant l'époque de wapiti et
whoopi dû composer avec ce qu'on avait
ainsi naquirent donc les illuminati
illuminé lumière c'est bon vous l'avez
leur objectif principal c'était
d'influencé en cachette les décisions
politiques et de perturber la monarchie
et l'église c'était le poil à gratter
des institutions qu en gros est
l'emblème des illuminati alors bas les
connaisseurs vont me dire que c'est ce
fameux oeil dans un triangle à vous
savez l'oeil de la providence eh bien
que nenni parce qu'en fait c'est la
chouette le symbole de la déesse athéna
est-ce que pourquoi pas quant à l'oeil
dans un triangle et bah c'est un symbole
qui n'est pas du tout spécifique aux
illuminati parce qu'on le retrouve aussi
sur des bâtiments maçonnique et des
églises et oui à la basse un symbole
chrétien chez les illuminés et les
francs-maçons cet oeil représenterait le
fait que ces groupes contrôlent et voit
tout un peu comme les caméras de
surveillance à nice d'ailleurs on
confond souvent les illuminati et les
francs-maçons alors c'est bien deux
entités distinctes mais elles ont vécu à
la même époque vice rapt avait même
pensé rejoindre une loge maçonnique au
début mais ça lui plaisait pas tout à
fait alors il s'est dit plutôt je vais
créer ma propre société secrète et
d'ailleurs les illuminati allait
régulièrement recrutés v man parmi les
adeptes du compas et de l'équerré les
francs-maçons un pas les mathématiciens
justement tant qu'on parle de
recrutement si jamais vous voulez
rejoindre l'ordre et bien c'est très
simple il vous faudra être bien né être
riche avoir une bonne réputation et être
approuvée à l'unanimité par les membres
du groupe dans ce cas vous deviendrez un
d'illuminati de level 1 un novice et
puis après un certain nombre de rituel
qu'on connaît toujours pas vous passer
au level deux puis trois puis quatre etc
et jusqu'au dernier level le 13 oui vous
appellera roi ou toute société secrète
oblige il ya plein plein de trucs qu'on
ignore encore sur ce qui s'y passe est
vraiment dans ses loges s'ils devaient
manger des omelettes aux girolles tous
les jeudis ou bien bien pensé à refermer
l'abattant de la cuvette des toilettes
sous peine de passer la nuit dans la
cage à chouette mais ce conseil c'est
que les membres devaient par exemple
porter un pseudonyme antique comme
spartacus je rigole pas dresser la liste
de leurs faiblesses et révéler les noms
de leurs ennemis c'est un peu un mélange
entre un entretien d'embauché death note
et il a eu du succès cet ordre bavarois
en 1784 il comptait entre 2000 et 3000
membres et noble des étudiants du
fondateur de l'ordre des médecins des
intellectuels des avocats et peut-être
même des stars de l'époque mais bon
c'est pas très bien vu que c'était
secret bon par contre il n'aura pas vécu
bien bien longtemps ce gang en 1785 le
duc de bavière a appris son existence
celle de la société secrète un pas de
l'uimm du coup il a promulgué plusieurs
et 10 pour dissoudre cette société
arrêter ses membres et puis carrément
les condamnés à mort et c'est ainsi que
s'est achevée l'histoire des illuminés
de bavière moins de dix ans après sa
naissance il dira qu on en parle encore
trois siècles après parce que selon une
théorie du complot bien connu mais sans
aucune preuve tangible cet ordre
continuerait d'exister dans l'ombre et
de tirer les ficelles du pouvoir prêt à
instaurer un nouvel ordre mondial on
retrouverait même des célébrités parmi
ses membres comme beyoncé ou jay-z par
jour assure à ils ont tous nié leur
implication là dedans et entre nous
est-ce que c'est pas exactement ce que
fera un illuminati perso je suis
intimement persuadé que les illuminati
sont derrière l'assassinât de jf kennedy
le 11 septembre 2001 la défaite de la
france à l'euro et le dernier album de
game et d'ailleurs je fais régulièrement
la chasse au triangle et à l'oeil de la
providence donc toutes les vidéos et les
photos que je vois pas c'est pas vous
en tout cas cette théorie du complot ne
date pas d'hier elle a été popularisée
en 1797 et 98 respectivement par le
scientifique écossais john missoni dans
le monde anglo saxon et le prêtre
jésuite augustin baru elle en france
bouquin de l'écossais s'appelle
attention accrochez votre ceinture les
preuves d'une conspiration contre toutes
les religions et gouvernements d'europe
fomenté par les sociétés secrètes des
francs maçons et des illuminati moins ça
a le mérite d'être clair et figurez vous
qu'il est toujours régulièrement citée
par les comploteurs et cette théorie
continuerait d'être véhiculé aujourd'hui
d'après l'historien stéphane françois
parmi les milieux d'extrême droite et
août eric marquée par le new age alors
le newedge c'est un courant spirituel
porté vers les chakras le pouvoir des
pierres tous ces trucs perso en tout cas
je vois pas du tout ce qui veut dire
allez je vous laisse c'est l'heure de ma
séance de silovo thérapie
[Musique]
m